[Music]
our next guest has become a social media
sensation for changing the way that
people think about food sam privet is
her name she's a registered dietitian
who's known for her very blunt and she's
blunt and honest very honest response to
the so-called diet culture her tick tock
account fine food freedom has more than
half a million followers she encourages
people to have fun with food i like that
and often has rather unexpected things
to say here she is
i didn't eat a vegetable yesterday
yep i said it nope didn't have one
vegetable yesterday i guess i had
roasted potatoes but i'm talking like a
green veggie a carrot
a bell pepper didn't have a vegetable
yesterday
didn't do it intentionally just wasn't
feeling it and guess what
i'm not unhealthy
i'm definitely not a bad person
and
i'm gonna be okay
now why i want to bring attention i like
how she thinks sam privette is also a
certified intuitive eating counselor or
practice she teaches her followers she
joins us now sam good morning to you
i've been running all over the building
looking for you because i thought you
were in-house but i forget covet is
keeping us apart but i'm so glad that
you're here listen you are preaching to
the choir
you are preaching to the choir when you
say diets don't work i have tried them
all including one that says only eat
when you're hungry and sam i found
myself going am i hungry right now
should i get something to eat it's so
stupid you'll drive yourself crazy so
you're talking about intuitive eating
what exactly does that mean
yes so intuitive eating is a self-care
framework of eating that has 10 defined
principles it has over 140 studies to
date and it was actually created back in
1995 so it is not new by any stretch it
was created by two registered dietitians
evelyn tripoli and elise fresh and this
self-care form of eating framework has
ten defined principles now for sake of
time i'm not gonna go through all ten
yeah but the mission of intuitive eating
is to help us regain trust with our body
drop the guilt and shame of food learn
how to
really quiet all of the external noise
of diet culture and turn inward to be
able to listen to our hunger cues our
fullness cues
and find joy and food and movement and
life again
you know there's so much guilt and shame
associated with food you say it's never
too late to heal that heal that
relationship why is it so difficult
that's such a great question we have our
oldest client is 79 years old and they
the thing we hear from all of our
clients is i wish i started this earlier
but i think it's so difficult because we
do live in a world surrounded by this 72
billion dollar diet industry that's full
of fads and pills and supplements and
quick fixes
really telling us that if we just lose
the weight we're going to be happy or
healthy but we know that's not the case
so
we really really help our clients just
drop that guilt and shame with food body
image so they can start to make behavior
changes that do make them feel pleasant
physically mentally and emotionally
sam it's vlad um you say that we should
listen to our hunger cues and our
fullness cues i'm good with the hunger
cues part it's the fullness part that i
never listened to so it is intuitive
dieting for me
so intuitive eating can absolutely be
for you it's for every body shape size
race gender sexuality
um truly intuitive eating is for
everybody and
with that hunger and fullness cues can
absolutely be felt and i think sometimes
the food freedom people think that that
means saying yes to all the food but
it's learning how to also respect our
body and say no when we genuinely aren't
hungry anymore
so that's something yes we also do with
intuitive eating
well sam uh my intuition shows up late
to the party often it tells me i'm full
after the fact and there's a little
thing called regret that comes over me
and i think part of the reason is
because forget about the diet industry
there's a food industry out there that
is trying to make me eat as much as
possible right they make it really good
really easy
how do people within the framework of
intuitive eating deal with that part of
things
and what exactly are you supposed to eat
i want to know that too
go ahead what was that girl
and what exactly are you supposed to eat
i like tony's question but i also want
to know before you leave what we're
supposed to be doing anything right
yeah it sounds like amazing yeah yes so
and you have less than a minute sam yeah
we'll shut up okay so we we want to make
sure that we realize that if we're
experiencing emotional unpleasantness
from food so let's say we feel
physically unpleasant and then we also
feel emotionally unpleasant
we don't want to experience that guilt
is a moral emotion we should only be
feeling guilt when we break moral code
right like stealing or cheating or maybe
taking a kid's ice cream cone and
running away and eating it so we're
feeling guilt or regret from food we
help clients remove that so they can
actually be present in their eating
experiences taste the food savor it and
enjoy it and to answer your question
gail no foods are off limits with
intuitive eating and
we yes right so we enjoy all foods and
that's because we know that restriction
fuels binging so i like to explain it
like a bow and arrow you pick your bow
and arrow up and say no carbs no carbs
no carbs you hit that breaking point
where you're like screw it i'm going to
eat all the carbs but when we allow
ourselves to have a neutral relationship
with food we can enjoy all right
sam thank you so much thank you sam
really nice to meet you